I'm excited about this me Oh jurors it
was intense but um I'm excited about
being prepared like this time last week
I was so insecure I stressed all day at
work remember you know it's nothing like
not having to stress so I'm gonna lend
out for my concert the child's been a
lot of work I'm still recovering with
being sick I mean my voice is pretty
much non-existent and I just have to
keep rehearsing dance with the Stars
while I'm here cuz I'm on the road I'm
gonna hurt a little bit tonight but
Marlo is blocked tomorrow from 11:00 and
12:45 and from 5:00 to 7:00 that's
is that guy's missing time you know
did you fall asleep remember my
conversation you tried it
yes you did no I saw your eyes now you
said I was there will you trust the eyes
one car no runs could've been cloned
okay whatever I was nicely done harder
than you say can't you ever is your
Moses you know my size that's my own
limited oh I like sleep Oh Joe potatoes
now don't talk to me
now I'm going to sleep I'm used to this
obviously why I'm talking to him I don't
understand what he does that is so
frustrating okay I was listening to my
eyes was just resting no when I was
still here - yeah I was asleep dog she's
just like now I could just go like this
you can't I think I just said I can't
hear